- I'm an introvert for sure
as I have a career despite myself.
When I grow up, I want to be famous.
I want to be a star.
I want to be in movies.
When I grow up, I want to see the world.
Drive nice cars.
I want to have groupies.
That's why I started out as a comedienne.
I started out to make people happy
and make people feel good.
Every single day that I do
my show, it is an energy
that is like no other energy.
Never follow someone else's
path unless you're in the woods
and you're lost and you see a path.
Then, by all means,
you should follow that.
Nobody wanted to hire me for three years.
I didn't have any offers.
(swooshes)
- She's an American comedienne, TV host,
writer, and producer.
She starred in a popular sitcom Ellen
and hosted the Ellen Degeneres Show.
She's won 13 Emmys and 14
People's Choice Awards.
She's Ellen Degeneres, and here's my take
on her top 10 rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and I'm curious to figure
out which one you guys
like the best, too.
(swooshes)
- I get the distinct impression
that while you may be
this famous talk show host,
you are a private person,
maybe even shy.
- I'm an introvert for sure
as I have a career despite myself.
'Cause I really am awkward socially.
I hate going to big events.
I hate having to do small talk.
I don't like a lot of attention.
- It's bold of you being an
introvert to not only do this
show, but to also put
yourself out there realizing
that not everybody's going to like you.
- If it costs me some
viewers, and if it costs
me some money, I'd rather
talk about what I think
is important than just
be, you know, vanilla,
and try to be liked by everybody.
- [Ann Curry] That honesty has
cost here, especially in 1997
when she famously came out of the closet.
- I'm gay. (audience applauds)
- [Ann Curry] Only to have
Hollywood shut the door.
Advertisers pulled out.
Within a year, her sitcom was canceled.
Her career stopped cold.
- I don't think it was a failure,
but it certainly gave me a lot
of free time for three years
to sit still and go, okay.
Who am I without a career?
Who am I without people loving me?
- Did you feel that you had
made a mistake in coming out?
- No.
Absolutely not.
- Why?
- Because I am free.
I am completely able
to be exactly who I am.
To have to hide anything is
just a horrible way to live.
When I was younger I thought success
was something different.
I thought when I grow
up, I want to be famous.
I want to be a star.
I want to be in movies.
When I grow up I want to see the world.
Drive nice cars.
I want to have groupies.
(audience laughs)
To quote the Pussycat Dolls.
How many people thought
it was boobies by the way?
It's not.
It's groupies.
(audience laughs)
But my idea of success is different today,
and as you grow, you'll
realize the definition
of success changes.
For many of you, today's
success is being able
to hold down 20 shots of tequila.
(audience laughs)
For me, the most important
thing in your life is
to live your life with
integrity and not to give in
to peer pressure to try to
be something that you're not,
to live your life as an honest
and compassionate person,
to contribute in some way.
This energy, I mean,
you can feel it in here.
And you've talked.
People come from very, very far away.
They fly here.
They make plans.
This is their vacation or their trip,
and they come in here and
bring this positive energy
and this love and this
joy, and I get to feel that
every single day.
It's the most amazing feeling
that that energy is coming
at me every day, and I hope
I give it back to them.
I hope they get that.
And I think if I do that every single day,
and I keep, I feel like I have a purpose.
I feel like I am, that's why
I started out as a comedienne.
I started out to make
people happy and make people
feel good, and I'm doing
it on a larger scale.
And I think if, I hope I can do this
for a long, long, long time.
- [Robin Roberts] But you're in front of
an audience all the time.
This is a big deal.
This is the Oscars.
What's the difference?
- Oh, there's a big difference.
That audience comes to
see me, and they travel
from, and God bless 'em.
They travel from all over the
world to come to a taping.
And they wait for a year for tickets.
They're my core group
of people that get me,
know me, and love me, and I feel that.
And that room is like church.
Really every single day that I do my show
it is an energy that is
like no other energy.
(audience claps and cheers)
- The way you are with
your audience is unlike
I think anything I've ever seen.
I mean, they really feel that they are,
they are a part of the show.
- Yeah, yeah, they are.
I mean, this is our 11th
season, and when we started
building the studio,
it was really important
that the audience was
comfortable, and it was really
important that they were not in the dark,
that they were lit because
they're a part of the show.
It's not a spotlight on me.
Of course, my lighting is better.
I'm a Cover Girl.
I have to look good.
(laughs)
But it's still bright enough
that they're part of it.
- You know you did a
very successful sitcom.
You came out.
And then it was canceled.
Has this show sort of saved
you do you think in a way?
- I think what saved
me is me being honest,
and I think I somehow had
the courage to do something
and say something that
I knew would possibly
end my career, and instead of
making business more important
I made my soul and my life more important.
And I think by being
truthful and by being honest
that saved me.
Then I was given the
opportunity to do something
where I could actually just be myself,
and people could see who I am.
And if they respond to it,
great, and if they don't, great.
And they responded.
Follow your passion.
Stay true to yourself.
Never follow someone else's
path unless you're in the woods
and your lost and you see a path.
Then, by all means,
you should follow that.
(audience laughs)
Don't give advice.
It'll come back and bite you in the ass.
Don't take anyone's advice.
So my advice to you is
to (audience laughs)
be true to yourself, and
everything will be fine.
And I know that a lot of you are concerned
about your future, but
there's no need to worry.
The economy is booming.
The job market is wide open.
(audience laughs)
The planet is just fine.
It's going to be great.
You've already survived a hurricane.
What else can happen to you?
As I mentioned before, some
of the most devastating
things that happen to you
will teach you the most.
And now you the right questions to ask
for your first job interview
like is it above sea level?
(audience laughs)
So to conclude my
conclusion that I previously
concluded in the common
cement speech, I guess
what I'm trying to say is life
is like one big Mardi Gras.
But instead of showing your
boobs, show people your brain.
And if they like what they
see, you'll have more beads
than you know what to do with.
- Do you carry any
resentment form that time?
- I'm furious.
(audience laughs)
- You were cranky at the time though.
- Oh, I was furious at the time.
You know, because when you're
new, and you all the sudden
are like, you know, I
just felt like I was,
and it was my own fault.
I kind of felt like I was
stuck living my life the way,
and if I, how dare they
not like me anymore just
because I suddenly revealed
the truth of who I am
in one aspect of my life.
I'm just saying I'm gay.
That's all I was saying, and I was so mad.
I was so mad that I lost my show.
I lost, not just my show,
but nobody wanted to hire me
for three years.
I didn't have any offers.
I mean, literally, the phone
did not ring for three years.
And I had no money.
I was out of money.
I was just so, that tends
to make people cranky.
(audience laughs)
And then you know, I just
kind of, it was good.
It was actually, I was very
grateful for that time.
I'm very grateful that
I got to experience,
it gave me more compassion.
I know what it feels
like to be out of money.
like to be up and high
and like, I was in a top-rated sitcom
and very successful, and
people treated me very well.
And then all of the sudden
just because of one revelation,
I just was the joke.
I was the punchline of
every late night talk show.
I was made fun of in magazines.
It was, and it felt horrible at the time.
And now, I look back, and
I'm so grateful for it
because it really gave me
a chance to examine myself
and say who are you without fame?
Who are you without success?
Who are you without money?
And I kind of found different parts of me
that would not have grown
had I not experienced that.
Most comedy is based on getting a laugh
at somebody else's expense.
And I find that that's
just a form of bullying
in a major way, so I want to be an example
that you can be funny and be
kind and make people laugh
without hurting somebody else's feelings.
- The big breakthrough was in 1986.
You were on with Johnny Carson, first time
with Johnny Carson, and he loved you.
You did a routine about
calling God on the phone.
- [Ellen] Right.
- [Barbara] I think he put
you on hold, didn't he?
- Well, it was a big place.
People talk about praying and
talking to God all the time,
but I just thought it would
be great if you could have
a phone conversation,
if you could actually
just reach God somehow, if you could just
pick up the phone and call God.
- [Barbara] If you were calling God today,
what would you say?
- Thank you.
- [Barbara] Oh, Ellen.
- Just I got nothin' but gratitude.
My whole life is just I'm so blessed.
I'm so lucky.
And I feel it every day.
- I was talking to some of your audience
before the show today, and I asked them
what they love about you, and
what they said unanimously
was your energy and your dancing.
Where did the dancing start?
- It really started as
such a ridiculous accident.
It was kind of, you know,
when I, even when I did
my sitcom when I was
introduced to the audience
before we would tape the
show, I just have always
loved music, and I always love to dance.
I mean, how could you not
dance when you hear music.
That's just sort of who I am.
When I hear music, I dance.
And then it became where I
would dance into the audience,
and then it just kind of,
I saw the audience respond
to it in a way that it freed
them up to just dance with me.
And I think people come here
almost, it doesn't really
matter who's on the show.
It's just a place to let go and be free.
And I mean, everyone in
this audience is, you know,
a stranger to the other.
People are from all over the
world, and they come here.
It's day time.
It's not dark in here.
They're not drunk as far as I know.
(audience laughs)
They may be.
I don't know.
And they're all dancing.
♫ You there
♫ Get you goin' like that
♫ Oh, baby, baby
- Man, oh, man, that
dance made me thirsty.
♫ Burn, baby burn
♫ Please don't stop
♫ Please don't stop the music
- All right.
You got a little move.
- And you know people just stop dancing.
I think people grow up,
and they stop playing games.
They stop playing Hide and Seek.
They stop, you know, we just grow up,
and we get so serious and stop playing.
And we stop dancing.
And you know, we get busy with our lives,
and the only time we dance
is maybe at a wedding,
and maybe if we're drunk
and maybe if there's
20 other people out there.
And nobody goes to clubs anymore.
And so it's a place to just,
you know, and to me dancing
represents just freedom and
letting go and having fun
and being a kid again.
So I think that's why they respond to it,
and that's why I do it.
(swooshes)
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Julia Kole asked me to,
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
me to profile next, leave
it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Ellen's top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
Leave it in the comments.
I will join in the discussion.
Thank you again for watching.
Continue to believe in
whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you soon.
(swooshes)